على حافة مخيم
نعيم خارج العاصمة
الصومالية زمزم محمد تظهر لنا القبور الجديدة
لأولئك الذين لقوا حتفهم هنا
واحد اثنان ثلاثة هناك 30 تقول إن
إجمالي
ضحايا الجفاف القياسي في هذا البلد
حيث أن مدير المخيم محمد
مكلف بدفن  طفل رضيع
جوز الهند الميت
من تلك الزاوية إلى هذه الزاوية
تقول إن هذا الخط من القبور هو كل
الأطفال يجب أن يثقل كاهل قلبك
لتضطر إلى دفن هؤلاء الأطفال الصغار الذين
تشعر بالحزن الشديد عندما
تدفن طفلًا تخبرنا
أنني أم و  أستطيع أن أشعر بألمهم
لأن أحد الوالدين على
بعد 500 ياردة ، لم تزور نورثا علي هومي
قبور أطفالها الثلاثة
الذين
يعانون من سوء التغذية الحاد ، وقد ماتوا بعد
إصابتهم بالحصبة ،
ولا أستطيع تحمل الذهاب.
يسير نحو مجاعة أخرى
ما يقرب من نصف البلاد جائع
وقد أجبر حوالي 800000 شخص
على ترك منازلهم هذا العام وحده ، لذا
قبل شهرين لم يكن هذا المخيم موجودًا حتى
الآن.  هناك أكثر من
870 عائلة تعيش هنا ، حيث الظروف
رهيبة واهتمام العالم في
مكان آخر على بعد
آلاف الأميال من الخطوط
الأمامية للحرب في أوكرانيا ، أصبح تأثير
غزو روسيا محسوسًا هنا
حيث ارتفعت أسعار الغذاء والوقود بشكل كبير مع حصار روسيا للقمح الأوكراني
يهدد الإمدادات العالمية ، فالقمح الذي
يتم
استهلاكه في الصومال يأتي 92 في المائة
منه من روسيا وأوكرانيا عندما تجمعوا
معًا ،
لذا فقد تضاعف سعر القمح في
بعض المناطق التي تعرف أنها زادت بنسبة 150 في المائة ،
لذلك
تمت تغطية تغير المناخ ولكن الحرب في
أوكرانيا  تهدد حقًا بدفع
الصومال إلى حافة الهاوية ، نعم بالتأكيد
نعم ، وماذا إذا استمرت الحرب
في أوكرانيا إذا استمر هذا الحصار في
مكانه ،
فما هو التأثير الذي سيحدث هنا ، لا
أستطيع أن أتخيل تأثير
جناح الاستقرار في مستشفى بنادير
على تقديم  لمحة عما
قد يأتي ، لا توجد أسرة فارغة والعديد من
الأطفال المرضى بشدة
هو في حالة فاقد للوعي
الدكتور حفسان  تعمل محمد حسن
على مدار الساعة على مدار الساعة
أصغر مرضاها على قيد الحياة كم عدد
السنوات التي عملت فيها في هذا
المستشفى ثماني سنوات ثماني
سنوات هل سبق لك أن رأيت الكثير من
الأطفال الذين يعانون من سوء التغذية ، لا
هذا أسوأ موقف أراه
وعدد  الحالات
تتزايد يومًا بعد يوم ، المستشفى
مشغول جدًا بهذه الحالات
، هل أنت مرهق ، نعم ،
الوضع
صعب للغاية في سرير واحد ، نلتقي هريدا عبدي
ابنها محمد البالغ من العمر أربع سنوات ،
لقد فقدت بالفعل ثلاثة أطفال في هذا
الجفاف تقول بهدوء  لذلك أتيت
إلى هنا لتنقذ ابنك ،
كيف تتعامل
مع هذا النوع من الخسارة لتفقد ثلاثة
أطفال ،
كيف تمر اليوم ،
لا يمكنني التعامل مع الموقف تقول
أنا فقط أدعو أطفالي الباقين على
قيد الحياة ،
إنها صلاة مشتركة  من قبل العديد من النساء
هنا لم يسمع العالم بعد